qualité c'est tout d'abord ce
déplacement ce matin de françois
hollande au château de versailles pour
une inauguration du nouveau pavillon
mais également en préfecture pour une
cérémonie d'hommage à jean baptiste
salvin et jessica schneider ce couple de
fonctionnaires de police tué à
magnanville le président était
accompagné du premier ministre et du
ministre de l'intérieur des familles des
victimes des représentants des forces de
l'ordre également vous le voyez aux
alentours à la population est venue
nombreuse assister à cette cérémonie
retransmise sur l'ensemble des chaînes
de télévision moment de recueillement ou
au cours au cours duquel le président de
la république a salué deux héros du
quotidien
parce qu'ils ont
j'étais là et l'eau
pleinement engagé les services dé france